Yo ! C'est Cyrus et bienvenue dans ce nouveau Coup de Phil
Vous trouvez pas que certaines histoires, films, pièces sont vraiment hardcores ?
J'pense par exemple à OEdipe
le mec il va tuer son père, coucher avec sa mère et se crever les yeux dans le plus grand calme.
Tu vois j'te parle des grosses tragédies.
(musique) "Est-ce que tu m'entends hé-ho"
Mais elles ne sont pas là que pour nous secouer,
elles sont là aussi pour nous faire vivre la catharsis
d'Aristote.
*Générique*
Aristote c'est un philosophe grec, disciple de Platon
qui s'est intéressé à beaucoup de choses.
Il s'est intéressé à l'art,
aux sciences -comme vous avez pu le voir chez e-penser,
il a même inventé la métaphysique.
Voilà, rien que ça.
Il a créé la logique, la biologie, bref c'est un personnage super intéressant.
Et il nous dit que parfois,
nous sommes sujets
à une épuration des passions
qu'il appelle Catharsis.
Pour que la catharsis fonctionne, il faut deux choses.
D'abord il faut qu'on puisse s'identifier aux acteurs des tragédies
que ce soit au cinéma, au théâtre ou dans la littérature.
Et pour ça c'est pas compliqué,
il faut que les personnages aient des vies ou des réactions
que l'on pourrait avoir.
-"Qu'est ce que tu fais ?
-"C'est trop triste ce qui lui arrive.
-"Mais c'est un pneu.
-"Oui mais je sais pas,
je me sens connectée
c'est peut-être à cause de ma pneumonie, je sais pas.
-Ça marche."
Il faut donc qu'il y ait une imitation de la vie
dans la représentation scénique
et ça tombe bien ça porte un nom
C'est la mimesis
"Mimesis... non c'est tout
je trouvais juste que ça avait un nom de pokémon"
La seconde chose c'est qu'Aristote dit
que quand tu regardes une représentation qui t'inspire
terreur ou pitié,
ça n'a pas du tout la même intensité que dans la réalité
"Eh bah dis donc il fait pas peur ce film"
*cris*
Donc du fait qu'on peut regarder une scène horrible et la supporter,
on va pouvoir avoir une prise de conscience
Et c'est ça pour Aristote qui permet de te purger
des émotions.
Alors évidemment c'est les émotions
qui sont en rapport avec la scène
Alors par exemple pour la scène horrible,
ça va permettre de te purger de la peur.
Ensuite pour l'aspect moral de la catharsis,
c'est-à-dire se purger des mauvaises passions,
eh bien quand tu vas regarder certains films
tu vas voir le destin tragique de personnages.
Et comme tu vis ce qu'ils vivent par procuration
-c'est-à-dire à travers eux-
Eh bien tu vas rejeter les passions qui sont à l'origine de leur destin tragique,
et comme ça tu te purges de ces passions.
Par exemple dans le film Scarface,
normalement t'as pas envie de finir comme lui
du coup, tu vas pas commencer à vendre de la coke
être malhonnête, hors-la-loi, avoir une soif de pouvoir, etc.
Après tu vas me dire que ça peut aussi pousser
à avoir des passions mauvaises
et j'vais dire que c'est un risque et que c'est un débat
très courant de le jeu vidéo
Par exemple pour GTA5,
est ce que ça me permet de purger mes passions
ou est ce que ça va me pousser à commettre des crimes ?
On peut voir aussi la catharsis sous un angle éducatif
puisque ça va nous apprendre à pratiquer nos émotions
et donc à les apprivoiser
et du coup on va diminuer notre sensibilité
pour être prêts à affronter le monde qui nous entoure
*cris de dégoût*
Ce qui est intéressant c'est que le terme est repris en psychanalyse
et que ça désigne en fait une méthode par hypnose
pour libérer des émotions enfouies
Tout est donc lié !
J'espère que la Catharsis est maintenant
un concept plus clair pour vous.
En tout cas n'hésitez pas à partager la vidéo si elle vous a plu
et à regarder les autres vidéos pour apprendre d'autres trucs cool.
Moi je vous envoie du love et de la peace,
Yallah !
*Générique de fin*
-"Et toi mec ?
-"Un peu.
-"C'est bien t'as pas rigolé"